hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Taylor
Bradley we're gonna check out the
trailer today for a horror flick called
good night mommy um interesting good
night mommy so I'm assuming someone's
probably kill his mom or something okay
patricide
that sounds really could be a sexual
thing that the mom and son are into it's
rated R for disturbing violent content
and some nudity maybe we see some cubes
on a badge hopefully not in the trailer
I know it's green man [ __ ]
ever
Oh
destice business don't somehow goodness
it's canceled such person
Oh
what in the [ __ ] with that I want to
watch that movie definitely looks cool
MA what cockroach was oh that was oh oh
my god I thought she was gonna like
scream or something so I was like Oliver
Barry I just was like that was a really
mouth warm huh what what an interesting
concept you know it's clever to have the
mom's face disguised cuz if you saw the
mom's face it probably wouldn't be as
scary yeah regularly interacting or
she's kind of quiet but the fact that
she's covered up as a plastic surgery
makes her that much scary I know I'm not
so interested in seeing these two kids
because he looked really talented
actually they look like these they're
willing to go to some dark places
yeah no no and it's like I would if your
mom all of a sudden was like completely
different when you want to know what was
going on of course you would do anything
to figure that out like you would
probably get really brave just to figure
out what was going on but it's like the
simplest idea for a monster it's like
just have you know the person who you
love the most and who loves you the most
not be themselves anymore
yeah and it makes for an interesting
compelling point because at one point
the kids like you're not my mom right
and I could be like metaphorically speak
I know it seems it made it seem like she
was full of cockroaches cuz there was
also that piece of time where she was
like cut open and all the cockroaches
came out like I feel like that has
something to do she's like connecting
with nature in a weird way yeah but I
don't know why the face surgery had
anything to do with her like going out
into the woods like there must have been
some some element that we're missing but
it seems like there's a supernatural
element here at play that's kind of
subtle right you know it doesn't seem
like there's it's gonna be overloaded
with like crazy [ __ ] but you can
definitely feel like maybe some type of
religious thing or some type of curse
yeah like you know yeah like there's
some type of
for natural horror element at play I'm
excited about it it started off with
like the the house in the middle of the
field was like oh this is every horror
movie ever what I like about it too is
it feels very tension-filled and creepy
and disturbing but not so much in the
visual aspect it's more so the tone oh
yeah like the music that they used for
it was very creative
yeah wait shot looks really well done
it's cool to see a movie that has all
these fear elements but it gets under
your skin but it's not so much about the
gore it's more so about situation and
that's my kind of favorite like that's
my favorite type of horror movie is the
ones that are just about mental like
[ __ ] with you mentally instead of
instead of cork scores just like gross
and there was nobody jump things either
which I was happy about oh yeah
it's like they had all those moments
when they built up to the jump and then
they like took you into a different
direction yeah oh yeah that's great
that's a good trailer good yeah it was I
want to see the movie anyway guys if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
check out Taylor Bradley's channel you
know if you're into film dear anything
artistically you're gonna like her
Channel and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter me on
vine and periscope let's do shout out
Tommy older plows plows haha why are you
Tommy all you guys are so freaking he -
- freaking or is that just no though
that's just freaking spot on my camera
my computer so freaking awesome when I
watch your videos I laugh so hard
haha plows hard especially at Ryan's
comments little laugh a shout out would
seem so much to me Tommy old applause
let's see who's plowing people these
days oh he's like teenie
oh you're teenie he's like ten uh but he
is in Gangster ten he's getting kisses
and then he has a glassy look like Tony
Soprano's son oh my god and he's got a
picture of Hitler okay you're not off to
a good young start my lad